- Here are the things
that run through my mind.
I would say the primary thing
I probably ask myself is, "Is this
"actually gonna lead to somebody
showing up at my funeral?"
If you really ask me what
the fuck I do for a living,
it's that I'm trying to create
a legacy because I'm either
A, so egotistical
that I want that.
- Yep.
- Or B, love
human beings so much,
'cause I do and I think that's
why I've popped on social.
- [Nickolas] Yeah.
- So I think a lot of what I
think about is what's the legacy
of this manuever.
- Yeah.
- Like right now, this
is fucking stupid for me.
Doing an interview
with you for 15 minutes,
is fucking ridiculous.
- I love it, I love it.
- It makes no God damn sense but
I'm feeling pretty good about
the odds of maybe this leading
to you showing up to my funeral.
That's how I think about stuff,
so I'm very big
on what it is impact,
how does it impact me
and more importantly the other
person in the narrative that
I care about which is I think
I was gifted with
some real crazy shit.
- Enough talent to be able to do
my thing for me and still have
so much left
over to give so much.
- To give, yeah, yeah.
- That to me is crazy.
(upbeat music)
- [Nickolas] Yeah.